[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
amanda knox reacts to the news of the
release of the convicted killer in her
roommate's death
an inside look into the italian trials
my prosecutors
downplayed the actions of the actual
killer
rudy g'day an update in the case of a
missing mother of five
could one defendant be turning on
another will we finally have answers to
what happened to jennifer doulos
and the owner of a new york bar arrested
again for violating corona virus
restrictions
this time the charges are more serious
you don't
assault a police officer plus
an undercover human trafficking
operation catches 14
suspects why major league baseball
umpire is facing charges
you would think an ump would be the kind
of guy
who knows and follows the rules
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
amanda knox is speaking out to abc news
about the release of rudy g'day
the only person still serving time for
the death of her former roommate
meredith character i continue to
stay to be shocked that he is the
forgotten killer
the one who is quietly tucked away
convicted of a lesser crime and
does not have to live with the burden
of being forever associated with
meredith's death
i do know that many many many people
have suffered a great deal
because of what he did i do wish that
he had been fully held accountable for
what he did
and that he acknowledged what he did
knox's conviction was overturned by an
italian court she spoke to law on crime
daily about how her case inspired her to
work on criminal justice reform
throughout my trial leading up to my
wrongful conviction i
genuinely believed that
it was truth beyond it was reasonable
doubt it was
innocent until proven guilty and i was
proven wrong
that was not the the prosecution was
never able to prove that i was
that i participated in this case what
they were able to do
was uh raise enough smoke to suggest to
people that there must be fire
and that is the case with all of these
wrongful convictions that are happening
in the united states my prosecutors
downplayed the actions of the actual
killer
rudy g'day and they forced me
into the equation by bringing up
random unverified slanderous
details that ultimately were irrelevant
to the case
or were simply not true so again we're
looking at these situations where
prosecutors and law enforcement are
incentivized to win at all costs
to not admit fault and in order to do so
they basically railroad innocent people
italian prosecutors had accused knox and
her then boyfriend
of killing kirkshire with g'day's help
but only good day's dna was discovered
at the scene
he was found guilty of murder and sexual
assault
i think that when i was going through
my interrogation the police didn't know
what happened
they thought that i knew what happened
and they thought
that there was some kind of sex game
that went awry because there had been
evidence that my
roommate had been assaulted sexually and
that
somehow i might know who might have done
it that i might have been involved
and if i a young woman with no criminal
record
were involved then it must be some kind
of
horrendous sex game that's the theory
and it all derived from trying to force
me into
a sexual assault murder equation
that i certainly did not fit into
g'day originally received a 30-year
sentence that was reduced to 16 years
the court this month allowed him to
finish the remaining two years of his
sentence
with community service here with me is
attorney terry austin to break down this
case
terry different country different laws
but what are your reactions to being
able to finish the last two years of
this kind of sentence with community
service you know
brian this is really difficult to accept
i mean this was
murder this was rape and murder and his
original sentence because it was
fast-tracked
to 16 years was not long enough as far
as i'm concerned
and then to get out you know a couple of
years
early to do community service i think is
an
injustice to the family so i'm not
you know happy with that situation i
don't think it's a good result now i can
kind of guess from your tone but let me
still ask the question do you think
this is a concept that we should
replicate in america or maybe steer far
far away of finishing a sentence with
community service
you know what it depends i think there
are some
sentences that can be commuted down to
community service
if in fact it's not violent if it's not
murder
but not if it's a murder case and not if
the case has already been
shortened because of a plea deal so to
speak i don't think that it should be
you know cut out to community service i
think that they should serve their time
agreed i don't think you want to paint
with a broad brush maybe some cases can
be finished with community service
and definitely others shouldn't be
thanks for that input terry
a man set to be executed this week for
his role in the murders of two youth
ministers
was denied a stay by a federal judge we
told you about brandon bernard's plea
for clemency last week
he was convicted in the murders of todd
and stacy
bagley during a robbery and kidnapping
at fort hood
in 1999. the shooter in the case was
executed in september
five of the jurors in bernard's trial
and a former prosecutor who actually
fought to uphold the death sentence
now believe his life should be spared
reality star kim kardashian also
supports the bid for clemency
bernard's attorney wants president trump
to commute his sentence
his lawyer says they'll appeal this
ruling
next to a tragic case of a child abuse
out of missouri
terry austin has more brian four people
in southern missouri are accused of
locking a four-year-old boy in a cage
the stone county sheriff's office says
the suspects lightly kept the boy in a
wooden crate constructed of
pallets for extended periods of time
authorities received a 911
saying the boy was unresponsive the boy
was taken to a nearby hospital then
airlifted to kansas city he reportedly
suffered multiple
injuries abuse and extreme
malnourishment
the suspects are charged with felony
child endangerment
i've stumbled to a lot of hard cases but
that's a difficult one to follow thanks
terry
uh still ahead on law and crime daily
undercover sting catches a big name
allegedly trying to solicit sex online
plus
the end of the saga involving charges of
prostitution against new england
patriots owner
robert kraft and the other defendants in
the case next
return to sports and the arrest of a
suspect for breaking into the
massachusetts home
of tom brady and his wife giselle bungen
brooklyn police say the former patriots
player was home
when the suspect walked in through an
unlocked door police arrested zanini
cenas after finding him laying on a
couch
in the middle of the basement cenis was
charged last year with stealing tom
brady's jersey
worth ten thousand dollars from the
patriots hall of fame brady and his wife
still own the home
but are currently living in florida
and now to the boxing ring where terry
austin has an update on a case we've
been following
on lawn crime daily that's right brian
boxer adrian broner was back in court in
cleveland over 860 thousand dollars he
owes a woman he assaulted
broner hasn't paid the judgment and the
judge in the case
isn't happy about it during a hearing
she made him answer questions
under oath about cars he owned after
threatening
to hold him in contempt for a second
time broner told the judge he had a big
fight in january which would allow him
to pay the money
but he now admits that's not true broner
has until next week to provide
information to the judge
about his finances tell me how to put
your money where your mouth
is there we moved to florida where two
plea deals ended the alleged
prostitution ring case that involved
patriots owner robert kraff
employees at the orchard of asia day spa
lee wang and sheng mingbi
agreed to plead guilty to one
misdemeanor charge of soliciting
prostitution
prosecutors were forced to drop charges
against the nfl owner
after the judge threw out police
undercover video the women
were sentenced to probation in order to
pay several thousand dollars
in fines fourteen men
face charges in ohio after being busted
in a human trafficking sting
and one of them works for the major
league baseball organization
law and crimes anjanet levy is here with
me giving details on the sting
and the high profile arrest
yeah brian these men were all arrested
over the weekend in a one-day
internet sex thing one is from
pennsylvania and another
it's from north carolina and then there
is another one who's actually from the
youngstown area in northeastern ohio
his name is brian o'nora he's a 57 year
old umpire for major league baseball
he's been with the league for 20 years
now
oh nora and the other men are charged
with two misdemeanors each
those are soliciting and possession of
criminal tools
ohio attorney general davio says this is
part of his effort
to stop human trafficking in ohio
look there is no human trafficking
without
somebody willing to put dollars on the
table uh
if the johns suddenly stopped buying sex
human trafficking would dry up overnight
so
it's important to hit both sides of this
this was a demand side operation and
really proud of our law enforcement
partners that
conducted it every time you go out to
buy sex in ohio
from another human being you're risking
being complicit
in this terrible modern day slavery
i reached out to major league baseball
for a comment on brian o'nora
so far they have not gotten back to me
brian
this was the second sting this fall that
the attorney general's office took part
in right
yeah that's right brian they have really
made this a priority in ohio
you may recall back in october we told
you about operation autumn hope
in that instance in that thing 45
missing children were recovered and 179
people were arrested
so the attorney general again reiterated
today
that stopping human trafficking in ohio
is one of his top priorities
thank you thanks for the update out of
ohio and jeanette
terry let's jump right in here ohio was
cracking down on john's but we've seen
cases like this
fall apart and those who are trafficked
end up being prosecuted
do you think this is a strikeout for the
14 defendants
you know i don't think it's a strikeout
for the 14 defendants but
it's going to be a home run for the
prosecution if in fact
there is some surveillance tape that was
properly secured
with a search warrant maybe this could
really be
good and you know we know from reports
that these individuals were
arrested when they arrived at a local
hotel
to pay for sex if any of that was caught
on tape maybe there is some surveillance
footage
that they can pick up that would be
really great for the prosecution to
really take this case to court
yeah but aren't these these 14
defendants kind of caught red-handed if
that's the situation they're online
they're saying hey i want to come over
i'll meet you at suss and such place
then they're found at such and such
place that seems pretty damning there
isn't it i could not agree with you more
that's why i say it's a home run for the
prosecution i think that it is extremely
damning
and that they would strike out as far as
the defendants are concerned because
they they would be going to jail because
i definitely think that
uh if they have any surveillance at all
whatsoever they're in trouble
couldn't agree more and since i'm out of
uh baseball puns let's move on
when we come back why the owner of a new
york bar is accused of trying to run
over a sheriff's deputy
and later suspects in the case of a
missing connecticut mother
appear to be pointing the finger at each
other do the police have a jailhouse
[Music]
informant
[Music]
the owner of staten island bar is
accused of ramming into a deputy trying
to arrest him
for defying coronavirus restrictions
danny presti of mack's public house
was already facing charges for allowing
crowds of patrons to eat and drink
inside
the owner declared the bar an autonomous
zone the new york city sheriff's
department says deputies went to arrest
him
for a second time when presti fled to
his jeep and drove with the deputy
clinging to the hood
new york's governor andrew cuomo had
harsh words for his supporters
a person who drove his car
into a law enforcement officer
drove a hundred yards with the law
enforcement officer
clinging to the hood for his life and
that's who their champion
that's who they're championing
someone who attacked a law enforcement
officer
you don't attack the nypd
you don't do it they're putting their
life on the line
you don't attack them you don't attack a
law enforce
enforcement officer who's doing his or
her job
and when you have someone who drives
their car
into someone could have killed him
hospitalizes him how dare you
what signal are you sending
so harsh words from the governor for his
supporters but terry
i'm thinking more of the staten island
prosecutor who didn't request
bail in this case i practice in this
state i practice in this city staten
island comes hard
when it comes to protecting their
officers this is blowing my mind
what are your thoughts on how this case
is being prosecuted so far
well staten island is like a country in
and of itself
it's not quite like the city it's not
quite like the state
you heard governor cuomo and he came
down hard
against an individual who is attempting
to assault a police officer and in fact
does assault a police officer
and the fact that the prosecution isn't
going after this
much you know more aggressively is
very difficult to accept and you know
the bail situation is even harder to
accept they should be going after this
very hard and let me put it this way as
a public defender
i support the bail reform i get it
people he's going to come back to court
he's a
he's a small business order in staten
island i don't think he's going to flee
the country of the state
he'll come back to court but does this
seem like unequal
treatment for different people when it
comes to assaulting an officer
a class d felony in the state where you
can do 15 years in jail
it doesn't seem like everyone's getting
the same treatment listen i am
definitely not a conspiracy theorist but
i guarantee you
if the person behind the wheel had been
a person of color
and rammed that jeep or car
into a police officer and dragged him
for a little bit
that tape showed that the police officer
was going for a while
that that police officer and his partner
might have you know
opened fire and we wouldn't be in this
exact same situation so i definitely
think
that the individual driving presti he
got
some preferential treatment there
because of who he is
and from my understanding this officer
did suffer serious injuries it's not
just a crime because of
who he injured but the fact of the
injury i think like injuries to his legs
like broken bones so wishing him a
speedy recovery but
the case still seems very curious as to
how the prosecutor's office is handling
it
when we come back new developments in
the case of a mother missing for more
than a year
her husband is dead could his friend be
revealing information
the story after the break
[Music]
one of the suspects implicated in the
disappearance and assumed death of a
connecticut mother
says that another defendant has flipped
jennifer doulos has been missing since
may of 2019
her estranged husband fotoz was charged
with her murder
but maintained his innocence he died by
an apparent suicide earlier this year
his former girlfriend michelle chirconis
as well as his friend
and former attorney kent mahini are
facing conspiracy charges in this case
michelle draconis's attorney john
schoenhorn is requesting
any alleged confessions made by kent
mahini in august or september of 2020
information about potential agreements
between prosecutors and muhini
in exchange for his cooperation medical
records of muahane's head injury
around the time of jennifer's
disappearance a scientific report about
a white protective suit
recovered this year in a wooded area
the defense's request comes as they
previously argued that
more discovery should be turned over
including photos police took
of troconis during a strip search
my client under the statue it does say
they need
an order from either the chief of police
or
a designated supervisor to even
authorize that the fact that the court
signed a search warrant allowing
photographs of
mission uh mr ponis's body did not say
anything about a strip search the
statutes are clear
i want to see that that was even done
number one number two those pictures are
missing they're not listed as evidence
they're not stored anyway i don't know
there's
nothing has been disclosed about where
those photographs
ended up there's a state police mail
wrote a description of each of the 25 or
30. i don't have that report in front of
me
photographs so he stood there and
looked at these pictures of my client
semi nude
and then wrote a description of each one
i don't know where these pictures are i
don't know if they were even
uh in a in a protected area for all i
know
they were passed around the state police
barracks and true l
and have been since i have had no
information what happened
to them terry troconis attorney is
calling kent mahini
a jailhouse informant this sounds like
someone could be pointing the fingers
and maybe
flipping to plants not plant evidence
but say that this is the one who
did it uh could that be disastrous for
traconis
oh it will be disastrous for to cronus
if in fact kent mahoney
says that she was involved and that it
was a murder and he helped dig the grave
i mean he is definitely
going to be implicating her to get a
better deal for himself so
i think her attorney is doing the right
thing by asking for
copies of everything including the plea
deal because he wants to see
what was promised to mohini and he wants
to see
what in fact was said about his client
now yeah exactly you kind of hit the
nail and had my next question we're
talking about potential promises to
mahini
does that mean there's a potential plea
deal for one defendant
and that defendant could be uh
testifying against the other
oh i definitely think he's going to be
testifying against the other
and one of the things i thought about
this case is there's
very little evidence against the
attorney here
against kent mohini and you know they
say he was digging the grave but i have
not heard that there's any sort of
you know dna recovered on the shovel et
cetera so
i definitely think he's going to try to
take a plea and i think he's going to
talk
and you know dulos is already gone he
you know apparent suicide and the only
one really left here is draconis and if
in fact
kent mulhaney can get a plea deal i
think he's going to do exactly that
so kent mahere might know more than the
rest of us do you think we could
possibly know what happened to jennifer
doulos after this plea deal
you know we know she's no longer with us
just because of you know the blood and
all of that that was found
but i think we will finally determine
what exactly happened to her because we
haven't heard those details and i'm
hoping we do
thanks terry and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you